I am fluent in the language of BS,
otherwise known
as business speak or bullshit,
depending on your point of view.
What is BS or business speak?
Business speak is the language
we use on the job and only on the job
to describe and define things.
For instance, at home,
I might say to my son,
"It's time to go. Are you ready?"
While at work, I'm more likely
to say to a colleague,
"Is it scalable? You can give me
a baseline ETA on departure.
(Laughter)
We need to leave ASAP."
Right?
I was first introduced
to the language of BS through my wife.
She's a chief marketing officer
for a global consulting firm,
and one day a few years back at home,
she was doing a conference
call on speaker,
and she started to use the language of BS.
I had never heard this woman
speak this language before.
I was concerned she was a spy.
(Laughter)
She used terms like "boil the ocean,"
"tiger team", "SWOT analysis."
Afterwards, she translated
those terms to me
in phrases that a human being
can actually understand.
And I did what every good partner
does in a solid marriage.
I made fun of those words ...
(Laughter)
relentlessly.
I may not make as much money
as my wife's colleagues,
I certainly don't have
the degrees they do,
but I know a messed up thing
when I hear it.
(Laughter)
And I devoted years of my life
to compiling, researching
and then writing a BS dictionary.
Yes. Thank you. Thank you.
(Applause)
I can now tell my kids that
an auditorium full of people applauded me
for all this worthless work
I did over the last few years.
So in the words of BS,
with this expertise
I say to you that
my presentation to you today,
the CTA of this DIY
TEDx Talk, if you will,
is a USP on the rise of BS
in our WIIFM world
and how we can make
this intel less scalable
during the fourth industrial revolution.
(Laughter)
If you don't understand
what I've just said, that's OK.
You don't speak BS.
(Laughter)
If you do understand what I've just said,
God help you.
(Laughter)
Yes.
(Applause)
So let me give it another shot.
I'll translate that in more common words.
The call to action
of my presentation to you
is to make the point that business speak
is on the rise in our globalized economy.
But there are simple things
we can all do in our day-to-day jobs
with that language
to take the bullshit out of BS.
So what I present to you is three ways
of how to take the BS
out of business speak.
First, you've been sitting for a while,
so let me poll the room.
I'm going to get your feet working here.
I want you to stomp your feet,
honestly, stomp your feet
if you know what the BS term EBITDA means.
(Stomping)
Nice. OK!
Maybe got some CEOs,
some accountants in the room.
Never know.
OK, now stomp your feet if you know
what earnings before interest, taxes,
depreciation and amortization means.
(Stomping)
A little bit more.
To be honest, I'm sure some of you
with amortization were like,
"I don't know if I should stomp." Right?
OK, now stomp your feet if you know
what income is before applying
accounting and tax write-offs to it.
(Stomping)
That’s a close call, but I’m going
to make a judgment call here.
The loudest stomping in this theater
got to the last definition
of the same thing.
EBITDA is basically income
before you apply accounting
and tax write-offs to it.
And notice that the most common language
got the biggest agreement
from this audience.
But here's the problem with BS.
It is not a common language.
Business speak
is the language of the elite.
Not surprisingly,
when my coauthor and I, Tim Ito,
researched about 300 business speak terms
for this dictionary,
one of the recurring themes
is the people who created this language
and speak it most fluently.
A large majority of them are people
who look like me.
A bunch of white guys.
I say that’s not surprisingly,
because I want you to think the first
and second industrial revolution,
when white guys like John D. Rockefeller
and Andrew Carnegie
ruled the business world.
And it's true today when research shows
that 90 percent of all
worldwide Fortune 500 company CEOs
are white guys, still.
So here's a takeaway for you in the room.
If you want to hang
with today's white male tycoons,
Bill Gates, Elon Musk,
Jeff Bezos, Warren Buffett,
it would benefit you to get
very adept and able to speak BS.
But there's a drawback to that approach.
I have a friend, Emily, who works
at a theatre company in the United States.
This theater company
does corporate entertainment
and keynote speeches for conferences.
She started her job a few years ago
and had her first big meeting
to try to make a sale.
It was with a big oil company in Dallas,
and across the boardroom from her
were five old white guys.
And Emily noticed very early on
that they did something very interesting
with their language choices.
They started to use BS words
that they knew she didn't know.
Now, why would they do that?
Three possible reasons. I talked to Emily.
We've worked out some theories.
One, these guys didn't know any better.
An economist, Robin Hogarth had coined
the term "the curse of knowledge"
to describe this phenomenon.
It may be simply that they're
so expert at their language,
that they don't appreciate anymore
what it's like to not know these things.
And they just spoke
off the top of their head.
As a corporate consultant
for public speaking,
the companies that I work for,
the reason I give them this advice
is because of that phenomenon.
I will tell them, If you have
a lot of BS in your four walls --
and it could be unique
just to your company
or it's just general acronyms
and things you use
in the business world --
and you have a new employee,
maybe give them a directory
of some of these terms.
So instead of walking into a meeting
and smiling and nodding
and then frantically googling afterwards,
what the hell does EBITDA mean,
that they'll know.
Second reason why
these five oil executives
possibly handled Emily this way:
they wanted to parse out from her
how much they knew --
how much she knew about the business.
Instead of asking her directly,
"Excuse me, Emily, can you tell me
how much experience
you have in our industry
and let's go from there,"
they used BS as a way
to keep Emily and them apart
rather than bring them together.
Third possible reason
these oil executives handled it that way:
they were just jerks.
(Laughter)
And Emily thinks that’s the answer.
Because shortly
after her initial conversation,
she brought in a more senior
male colleague,
lo and behold, the five
oil executives warm up,
they cut out the BS, and a deal is struck
shortly thereafter.
So that's something for us to think about
as our first takeaway of how
to take the BS out of business speak.
Use BS to be inclusive and not exclusive.
In other words, don't be a jerk.
(Laughter)
If you can explain something
in common language,
that's a victory.
The edit is the genius,
not spouting off all these big words.
Which brings me to my second takeaway
of how to take BS out of business speak.
Let's get those feet stomping again.
How many of you stomp your feet
if you know what the word
"de minimis" means?
(Stomping)
OK, good. I don't feel so alone
because I was a like a lot of you
who did not stomp your feet
a few years back.
As was mentioned in my intro,
I used to work for
“The Daily Show with Jon Stewart.”
For those of you who don't know,
it is a comedy show
that's nationally broadcast in America
that satirized the news of the day.
And I was interviewing an accountant
about a tax issue that he used
the word "de minimis" to describe.
And I interrupted him right there
and I said, "What?
What the F does that mean?"
And he said, "It means small, immaterial.
It's insignificant."
To which I said, "Well,
why didn't you just say that?"
(Laughter)
And he said in a moment of honesty,
he said, "I just thought it sounded good."
(Laughter)
In reality, it’s kind of
a cool word, “de minimis.”
And I'm guilty of doing it, too,
especially in a business meeting
where I'm unsure
of my status in that room.
I may use EBITDA, right?
Just to show, "Hey,
I can hang. I can hang."
(Laughter)
But here's the thing about communication.
You know what's really cool
about good communication,
especially in the business world?
It's when you can express fresh ideas
without using stale business cliches
and big words that people in the room
don't really understand.
So that's my second way to take the BS
out of business language.
For you.
To drive this home even further,
a lady that I worked with
in my corporate work
works for a big American company,
one of the biggest companies in America,
if not the world.
She works for bosses
that use a ton of business cliches,
so much so to keep herself sane,
she told me she created
homemade BS bingo cards,
(Laughter)
replaced the numbers in the bingo cards
with the phrases that they used
over and over again.
So when they turned up the BS
in a conference call,
she tuned out and tried to play bingo.
B: Think outside the box.
I: change agent. N: paradigm shift, right?
So these are things for us to think about.
That if we're using BS, a lot of it,
in our business speak,
it may be like Shakespeare said,
"sound and fury, signifying nothing."
Which brings me to my final takeaway
of how to take BS out of business speak.
Let's stick with Shakespeare.
Shakespeare has given us
some great BS speak
and stuff that allows itself to exist
outside of business speak
in the English language.
"Wild goose chase."
Think about this.
Kind of a weird reference.
That's from Shakespeare.
"Break the ice," "in a pickle" --
all from Shakespeare.
The good news is when we hear
references like this from Shakespeare,
a lot of us in the world
at least have a little bit
of an experience with Shakespeare.
And we have context clues,
we can figure it out.
But I want you to think
of other cultural touchpoints
that aren't as common as Shakespeare.
I'm going to put up some phrases
that are commonly used in America,
and if you know its common origin,
just yell it out.
If you're wrong, it's OK.
We'll edit it out of the video.
(Laughter)
"Swing for the fences,"
"out of left field," "rain check,"
“off base,” “pinch hitter,”
“right off the bat,” anybody know?
(Audience) Baseball!
Baseball! There you go.
I'm going to put up
another list of phrases.
Again, you tell me
what the common origin is.
"Blind leading the blind,"
"by the skin of your teeth,"
"fly in the ointment,"
"writing is on the wall."
(Audience) The Bible.
The Bible.
I suppose you have a Bible.
You're reading scripture between speakers,
like good Christians. OK.
Yeah, you're right.
"No rest for the wicked"
also comes from the Bible.
Here's my point.
Think of the global economy now.
And the majority of people on this Earth
don’t have daily experience
with American baseball,
and they don't read the Bible.
But you're sitting in a business meeting,
saying, "We have no time,
no rest for the wicked."
"The writing is on the wall."
Do they know what you're talking about?
Clap your hands if you've ever heard
the American phrase
"drinking the Kool-Aid."
(Applause)
Great. Anybody who clapped their hands,
what does it mean?
(Laughter)
It's a --
What's that?
(Unclear voice from the audience)
We'll get there. We'll get there.
(Laughter)
You've read my script.
You know where I'm going.
What does "drinking the Kool-Aid" --
What does that mean?
(Audience) Succumbing to peer pressure.
Succumbing to peer pressure.
It's kind of in there.
It's accepting something without question.
Just sort of like I did with you guys,
saying, "Stomp your feet."
You're just like, "Sure, whatever," right?
Yes. And to the balcony's response,
here's the origin story
of "drinking the Kool-Aid."
And the reason why I bring this up
is because it's important to know
the origin story of some of our BS.
Jim Jones is a cult leader. He's adorable.
1978. He has a great idea.
All of his hundreds of followers,
he's going to give them a delicious drink.
That's wonderful of Jim Jones to do.
He flavors it with something
called Flavor Aid,
which is popular at the time.
It's later confused in history
with the more popular flavored drink
in America called Kool-Aid.
But Jim made a bad mistake
with that Kool-Aid, man.
He'd laced it with cyanide.
Hundreds of followers
drink the cyanide and die.
1978. That's the origin story
of "drinking the Kool-Aid."
The reason I bring that up
is because a European audience,
you're like, "What is Kool-Aid?"
Also, if you're born beyond 1978,
you may not even know what this is.
Who is this guy?
What are you talking about?
Mass suicide? A cult with Kool-Aid?
"Drinking the Kool-Aid."
And there are other BS phrases
that fall in this category.
We've lost the origin story,
it gets muddied.
Think of TED Talk. The internet.
If you type “who founded TED?”
or “where did TED come from?,”
it's a person on the internet.
It's Technology, Entertainment, Design.
That's what TED Talks stands for.
Think of the BS phrase "piggyback."
You ever seen two pigs
with one pig on its back?
(Laughter)
I haven't either. Here's why.
Because the origin story of this phrase
is actually "pick back"
or "pick pack."
But it was so commonly
misstated as "piggyback"
that that mispronunciation was adopted,
and now it means “piggyback.”
And pigs are like,
"What the hell are you talking about?"
(Laughter)
And there are lots more like this.
Because we're up against lunch,
I won't bore you with an origin story.
It's a true one, it's horrible,
about the BS phrase "blowing smoke
up your ass," for example.
But I won't go there.
(Laughter)
Here's the takeaway out of all of this,
is that BS terms
can get lost in translation.
And I want you to think
of some of your own cultural BS
that we use around the world.
For example, in America,
if a company is without money,
you might say it's broke.
In Italy, you would say
it's "in the green."
In Spain, you would say
it's "without white," right?
In America, if you're doing
a very easy task,
you might say it was "a piece of cake."
In New Zealand, you'd say
"Bob's your uncle," right?
If you have a very hard task
that will never happen,
in America you would probably say,
"Oh, it'll happen when pigs fly."
In the Netherlands,
a Dutch worker would say,
"When the calves dance on the ice."
(Laughter)
And in Russia they would say,
"When a crayfish whistles
from the mountaintop."
It means the same thing.
In Japan, if you are doing a work task
and you need help,
you're desperate for anybody.
You may say, "I'll adopt cat paws."
In America, if you are given a task
that is one day over a long-term project
and man, you're just getting started,
you may say that
it’s “a drop in the bucket.”
In China, they have
the same idea communicated
through the phrase of
"nine cows and only one cow thread."
So those are examples
of cultural differences with BS.
And I'd be remiss to leave you for lunch
without calling out
some of the regional fondness for food
in your BS, in the German language.
Think of yourself, when you're
in a business meeting in Germany
or in Austria, with the German language,
if you want to add your two cents
in America, you'd say "two cents."
Here you say, "I want to add my mustard."
(Laughter)
OK? And once you get that mustard,
you want to be “clear as dumpling broth”
about what you’re trying to say, right?
You certainly don't want to come across
as somebody who has “tomatoes
on their eyes,” you know?
And the last thing
you want to do in that scenario
is you don’t want to “talk around
the hot porridge.”
OK? Which is the equivalent
of “beating around the bush”
with American BS.
I've given you a lot of bullshit
over a short amount of time,
so I'm going to wrap it up
with a little BS language
and we'll recap here.
In BS, what I am trying to say
is disambiguate the net net
of this dog and pony show
for you thought leaders.
(Laughter)
And I'm going to call out
the elephant in the room
with the three takeaways here.
First takeaway: use BS
to be inclusive, not exclusive.
Second takeaway is to make sure
that you express fresh ideas
without stale business cliches
or big words that maybe your audience
doesn't really understand.
And then finally appreciate
that a lot of our BS
is lost in translation
depending on the audience.
If we can all do this,
starting at lunchtime,
think of how little less bullshit
there would be in the world.
And what a wonderful thing that would be.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)